[Music]
all right so as biden leads from behind
tries to play phony tough guy with putin
it was donald trump who laid out the
dangers of europe's dependence on
russian oil and of course their lack of
pain their fair share for nato and the
dangers of europe willingly making
russia rich and putin rich again take a
look
i think energy is a much different story
than normal trade
and you have a country like poland that
won't accept
the gas you take a look at some of the
countries that won't accept it because
they don't want to be captive to russia
but germany as far as i'm concerned is
captive to russia because it's getting
so much of its energy from russia so
we're supposed to protect germany but
they're getting their energy
from russia explain that and it can't be
explained you know
and as former president trump also
warned china is absolutely going after
taiwan to pursue so-called reunification
amid biden's constant foreign policy
missteps here with reaction as you can
see is sitting right next to donald
trump former secretary of state fox news
contributor mike pompeo
we played five minutes of that
and there's the president of the united
states
he was in the face of the head of nato
and laying out the strongest case i've
ever heard of why in god's name are we
paying the bulk of money to protect
every one of our allied countries every
nato country they're paying far less
than we are even as a percentage of gdp
and we're we're paying it to protect
them from russia and they're making
russia and putin rich again now i've
known you for a long time and i think
you were the only other person besides
donald trump that was comfortable with
that entire conversation
sean i remember well i was incredibly
comfortable this is this is what friends
do for friends you tell the truth you
speak the reality you don't live in a
fantasy land you don't pretend it's okay
it's not it's not okay to send american
kids to fight and to american dollars to
go support you if you're not prepared to
do it yourself that's what he spoke to
the europeans on that entire trip not
just in that morning breakfast as i
remember but the entire time we were
there we wanted europe to stand up and
do the work to defend itself and then
we'd be with them we'll support you but
you got to take the lead this is your
this is your neck of the woods in the
first instance and we'd also understood
we had to shut down the nordstrom 2
pipeline so we sanctioned it you
couldn't let germany suffer by being so
dependent on russian gas and we can see
the results now biden comes in allows
the north stream to pipeline to continue
to be completed and it's not surprising
that we're seeing the results on the
ground in southeast ukraine as we sit
here today and be clear that that you
and president trump prevented the waiver
for the for the nordstrom pipeline um
we've heard similar language from putin
as it relates to the baltics in 2014 he
annexed crimea uh we see the possibility
of potential
military action and activities going on
in belarus you tell me is this going to
take all of ukraine or the territorial
ambitions of putin now to take over
ukraine and where do we go from there
sean it depends on the reaction of the
west this is not predetermined putin's
it's not inevitable this happened
because of the good work that president
trump and our team did it didn't happen
on our watch the only thing that's
changed sean vladimir putin didn't
change american leadership changed and
so you're right whether it was crimea or
abkhazia or the other places putin has
taken little chunks of sovereign nations
it'll continue to happen so long as the
united states is on its back foot and
the sanctions i've seen so far heck one
of the two banks they sanctioned a bank
called veb was already under sanctions
sean i promise you putin saw that and
what he reads in that is green light
these folks aren't going to take this
seriously
and unfortunately and this impacts
people at home we're going to have
higher gasoline prices because they've
shut down our energy and now russia will
make a fortune off of high gas prices
this is bad for americans all across the
country president biden needs to get
back out in front of this re-establish
deterrence and demand that our european
partners do exactly the same thing you
know the last time you were on this
program i asked you if you agreed with
me that the three areas in the world we
got to watch is russia and ukraine and
china and taiwan you're headed to taiwan
i want to hear more about that and then
obviously the muellers and iran uh the
olympics are now over i would imagine
after watching uh and listening to the
rhetoric of china talking about
reunification that's not reunification
that's taking over a sovereign nation uh
flying their fighter jets over taiwan
airspace uh the crackdown in hong kong
covert 19
the uyghurs being oppressed forced labor
etc
anything joe's going to be able to do to
stop the communist chinese from taking
over taiwan because i don't see what
he's what he could possibly do
america has the tools we have the
capacity to support the taiwanese people
we absolutely can we we did it for four
years everyone knows exactly what levers
there are the economic relationship to
provide them with weapon systems to
provide them with diplomatic support
sean that's why i'm going i want them to
know that there are many americans who
want the people of taiwan to continue to
live the life that they've lived and not
be under the jackboot of the chinese
communist party he has the tools sean
it's simply not clear if they're
prepared to engage in the world in a way
that protects the things that matter
most most to america and most of the
countries all around the world that for
so long have looked to us as that beacon
of freedom i haven't seen them use them
i pray that they will begin to do so
what do you make of this unholy alliance
that has emerged and that is russia
china and iran it seems that russia and
china are helping iran in their pursuit
of nuclear weapons do you see the same
thing
i do you know as you go through that
list of countries sean i've been
sanctioned by two of those three perhaps
the third one's on its way as well
look
they're going they're going to work
together because they don't have very
many friends in the world but if we're
weak
countries in the middle east will grow
closer to them countries in southeast
asia won't feel like they can push back
against china
those countries don't need our soldiers
they don't even often ask for them what
they want is they want to know that the
united states is with them we're their
friend if you want to engage in commerce
with us we'll be right there alongside
you i don't think they have confidence
that the united states under president
biden will do that and and for that
reason i think this axis this axis
between china iran and russia will
continue to grow and they'll make more
and more friends the weaker that we are
if we could work it out we'd love to
have you on from taiwan this is pivotal
i think the territorial ambitions of the
communist chinese are as clear as the
territorial ambitions of russia and
putin uh mr secretary thank you for
being with us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else